this week on the climate show you find
me in bed as I experience the romance of
newly rekindled night train travel
across Europe and it's a Greener way to
go
[Music]
this week on the show great excitement
for me and many people around me because
I'm about to board one of the first of a
new breed of sleeper trains this one
will be going from Brussels to Berlin
and it's part of a European push to kick
the short haul flight habit and green up
transport
oh also on the show
why activists are calling Northern
Ireland a wild west of environmental
regulation as they fight plans for a
mine in the Sperry mountains and 70
years on from the first Ascent of
Everest what could the Himalayas look
like in another 70 years
can't wait but how did I get here well
it all started back in London
London Saint Pancras international
jumping off point for low-carbon
international travel the start of a big
European Adventure but Brussels isn't my
destination I'm changing there onto this
train that will take me all the way to
Berlin overnight
party atmosphere this is the first train
from a brand new crowdfunded company
from today it will run three times a
week with prices for a flat bed in a
shared compartment starting at around 70
pounds or double that for a cabin of
your own
[Music]
pulling out of Brussels station
I know in many ways it's just a train
but it can't help but feel different
when you know you're going to spend the
night on it
once in a state of seemingly terminal
decline after the expansion of budget
flights Europe's night trains are having
a moment fueled by demand for greener
travel options new routes are now once
again snaking across the continent
including my train from Brussels to
Berlin
it takes around 12 hours to reach the
German Capital taking a deliberately
long way round to pick up more
passengers in Antwerp Rotterdam and
Amsterdam it's a high risk Venture in an
era of cheap air travel and the founders
have their family board for the big day
Chris why yes it's so important and and
of course because I like to travel by
Night Train myself but it's an important
thing to to get on track again in in
Western Europe the the international
Night Train but why is it important I
mean it's a huge gamble you're taking
here yeah but I like to do that and the
the the reason is that it's sustainable
traveling it's Pleasant traveling and
it's just uh missing and we really
believe also in the the possibility to
have it profitable why a Night Train why
not just a long distance fast train
um yeah the Night Train is more is a
very important aspect of uh because you
can cover a longer distance
on a High Speed Line you can do six
hours seven hours and you get tired
you'll get to Frankfurt or to Paris and
but on a night train you have a wider
range you can all go all the way to
Barcelona Milan Prague Copenhagen and
then still it's time efficient
so it's a it's very good competition to
airplanes
we don't have to persuade everybody
to come by train if we would have five
percent of the the current flights
Travelers then we would be fully booked
every day
trying to persuade passengers to swap
planes for trains is something this rail
expert has been doing for over two
decades it feels great to be back on the
sleeper train again there's nothing like
it leaving the evening arrive in the
morning and have your own space and your
own comfortable bed on board what do you
think it is it it is about the sleepers
that just give them that it's almost
like time travel isn't it well it's a
combination of the Practical lever City
Center in the evening
sleep the night away in your own bed and
arrive for fully morning in a completely
different country in a completely
different city and the fact that it's
such an enjoyable experience you know
open a beer or bottle of wine
snuggle down in bed between crisp clean
sheets listening to steel wheels swish
on steel rail beneath you it's it's
absolutely great and it's nothing like
the stresses of taking a plane and going
to an airport
sleeper trains raise expectations of
golden age glamor especially if like me
you feasted on Agatha Christie or Bond
movies for much of your life
the reality is a little less Fancy no
dining car but bring your own
supermarket food in plastic and eat it
off paper plates but there is still no
denying the romance of Crossing European
borders overnight not least with your
wife cheers
and traveling From Dusk Till Dawn
certainly seems to have Charmed my
fellow passengers
what do you think about this sleeper
train
is this so far yeah why are you on it
I'm on it because I wrote books about
train travel so this is right up my
street why do you think it's important
to have new sleeper trains like this
because I think it's important to offer
people different ways of travel that
aren't flying I think we're all very
concerned and we should be but climate
change and I think it's also a really
fun way of traveling
the thumb that's important yeah the fun
bit's really important the only downside
I would say is no dining car on board
because that's the Hub of all the
activity and where you get to meet
everyone and you get to have a lot of
fun but at the same time I still think
this is a very sort of massive sense of
community that you don't get on any
other form of Transport I wanted to
visit some friends in Berlin and I
decided that I wanted to reduce my
carbon footprint and so I'm going my
train overnight and I love a train
journey not that I'm a geek and so I'm
just part of the experience and I'm
really excited to be part of history and
I think it's the way to travel it's a
kind of a romantic way to travel and
it's a very good way to travel in a long
distance and stepping back it looks like
you're very well set here you can have a
meal and a drink and then you can we are
having a little a little party actually
[Music]
the expansion of night trains has
support from the EU was part of its
mission to cut the continent's carbon
footprint France has just banned short
haul flights on Journeys that take less
than two and a half hours by Rail and
the Belgian government is promising to
subsidize night trains like this
as we voted yesterday in the our federal
Parliament the first law in Europe to
help Night Train to develop a each night
range which will come to Brussels of
starts from Brussels will be free of
charge for the cost of the past and the
cost of energy you need to make a train
ride I want to make Russell hub for my
twins we have already trains coming from
Vienna three times a week in some months
five times a week to Berlin I hope to
have trains going to the south of Europe
and as a capital for for Europe it's
very important to have such
International trines there are still
many obstacles not least the lack of
sleeper carriages the ones on this route
are aging and rented but European
sleeper will be developing its own in
time and in 2025 plan to launch a second
route down to Barcelona with a Handy
Stop for Brits at Lille just an hour 20
from London well it's time for me to do
the sleeping bit now so good night see
you in Berlin
so is it a new dawn for sustainable
travel flight numbers are growing but
still below pre-pandemic levels More
Night Riders could slow this climate
damaging trend
come in come in good morning good
morning oh lovely thank you very much
indeed well here we are it's morning
it's Berlin we're just rolling gently
into town I slept pretty well
a bit of a problem with the temperature
control in the cabin and these blinds
flew up and down a couple of times but
so good to wake up in another country
after
sleeping horizontally
don't forget to take your luggage with
you when you get off the train on behalf
of your bin sleeper and the entire crew
We Wish You A Pleasant City
well here we are Berlin
let's go
we made it heart of Berlin the iconic
Brandenburg gate I'm going to spend the
day here and we'll get the train back
tomorrow but on the show we're off to
Northern Ireland now where plans for a
new gold mine in the sparing mountains
are causing considerable alarm
environmentalists say the province is a
bit of a wild west when it comes to
environmental regulation and they want
the mine stopped here's our senior
Island correspondent David Blevins
staking a claim to the land if the
Machinery come here we will lie down on
the road and we will stop it
protesters have set up camp in the
sparran mountains their opposing plans
for a gold mine fearing it will wreak
havoc on the environment half a million
gallons of water every day of the year
for 20 years from the peatland the bog
surrounding the site and as we know
peatland is a major carbon store but on
top of that if they are allowed to
abstract water from the Petland around
here that will destroy the aquifers the
rivers the streams Etc
it's an American company that's doing
the exploring here we took the concerns
of the protesters to its Belfast
headquarters you can go out and you can
speak to any climate scientist in the
world and I think that they all agree on
one thing
that we need to either vastly reduce or
perhaps eradicate our Reliance on fossil
fuels we can only do it by a huge
increase in Renewables and if we're
going to build those installations and
we're going to build the infrastructure
in order to get that power into the
point of use we're going to need a huge
new set of sources of minerals and
metals
last year an industry body listed both
Northern Ireland and the Republic in the
top 10 most attractive places in the
world for mining companies this island
has been described as the wild west of
Europe for environmental regulation and
it's not difficult to see why in
Northern Ireland 25 of the land is
licensed for mining compared to just 0.2
percent in England and in the Republic
of Ireland it's a staggering 27 percent
James Orr from Friends of the earth
claims the push for investment since the
troubles ended has taken priority over
the environment for many people within
the establishment of Northern Ireland
they regard Northern Ireland has now
been open for business that's the
language they use and it's as if we have
had trumpian economic policies in terms
of deregulation of Environmental
Protections many years before people
even knew what Donald Trump was all
about
[Music]
around the globe I
asked from The Standing Rock protest in
North Dakota came to show solidarity
sometimes and so we really think it's
important for us to stand together
it's not the first legal dispute over
these Hills this mine nearby is decades
old mining methods have modernized since
but not enough for some who call this
place home
David Blevins Sky News in the sparran
mountains
David Blevins joins me now uh David I
was really struck by that statistic in
your piece about the proportion of land
that's available for mining in both
Northern Ireland and the Republic how do
we get to that
well Friends of the Earth would say it
was virtually impossible to be an
environmentalist in Northern Ireland
during 30 years of conflict because
people had greater priorities the desire
to establish peace but they also say
it's been just as difficult to be an
environmentalist since the Good Friday
agreement because again people have
greater priorities the need to grow the
economy and that's why they talk about
trumpian economics suggesting that
success of governments in Northern
Ireland particularly have prioritized
investment over the environment the need
for jobs here but I think there is
perhaps another element that is unique
to this island and explains why the
figure is also so high in the Republic
and it is the fact that in this very
rural Society people tend to be very
territorial about their land if an
englishman's home is his castle an
irishman's land is his kingdom and
therefore it's very difficult to get
consensus and Regulation and difficult
for it to be enforced yeah I've got a
little bit of experience of that from
from them covering the rural side in in
Northern Ireland and it is very
difficult different from here from in
the rest of the UK there is still real
sort of power and pride in the land and
who controls it isn't it
that's right and I think it was perhaps
best Illustrated in some environmental
legislation that was passed by the
Northern Ireland assembly just before
the last election there were two bills
came at the same time one of private
members bill from the then leader of the
greens in Northern Ireland and the other
much less ambitious from the minister of
Agriculture who is himself from a
farming background and surprise surprise
it was the less ambitious bill that
passed you mentioned the administration
and of course environmental matters are
devolved from Westminster down to the
different countries of of the UK and so
how is the current paralysis installment
affecting the whole world of
environmental regulation well Stormont
is mothballed right now because the dup
continues to boycott power sharing over
post-brexit trading arrangements and it
is affecting just about every aspect of
life including the environment and uh
the environment is regulated by the
Northern Ireland environment agency that
falls under the Department of
Agriculture but that's one of the
Departments currently without a minister
it does though still have a permanent
secretary in charge and therefore the
agency continues to enforce
environmental regulation across Northern
Ireland but it can only enforce the law
as it stands and as we've just been
discussing there is limited regulation
here in Northern Ireland but the agency
would argue that it is doing its job and
certainly the mining company that has
applied for the gold mine in County
Tyrone says it does not have any
experience of an agency not regulating
not enforcing the law as it stands in
Northern Ireland
thank you very much indeed well that's
it for this part of the show we're going
to go off to a break now when we come
back we'll be on the top of the world
reporting on how climate change is
affecting Everest and the rest of the
Himalayas
foreign
welcome back to the climate show now a
few weeks back we brought you news about
how an election in Canada's oil
producing province of Alberta could have
a major impact on the country's climate
goals it pitted populist conservative
Danielle Smith against her center-left
NDP Challenger Rachel notley and this
week brought the news that the staunchly
pro oil and gas Smith had prevailed
setting Alberta on a collision course
with Justin Trudeau's federal government
in the
generation from natural gas in addition
the prime minister is already ready to
introduce a de facto production cap on
our oil and gas sector and as Premier I
cannot under any circumstances allow
these contemplated Federal policies to
be inflicted upon albertans I simply
can't and I won't
it comes as Canada continues to suffer
from an early and vicious Wildfire
season the Eastern province of Nova
Scotia has been badly impacted with
hundreds of homes destroyed and over 16
000 people evacuated as the blazes
remain out of control huge clouds of
smoke sit over its biggest city Halifax
and air quality warnings have been
issued for major U.S cities like New
York and Boston as smoke spread south
we also told you earlier this year about
ongoing negotiations for a legally
binding Global treaty on plastic
pollution negotiators have been meeting
this week for the second round of talks
in Paris many countries including
Britain are part of the so-called High
ambition Coalition calling for a treaty
to reduce the amount of plastic we
actually produce
but plastic producing countries like the
US and Saudi Arabia resist that
preferring to focus on improved
recycling
it's now 70 years since Edmond Hillary
and tensing Norgay first summited
Everest but a lot has changed in the
climate since then and that's been
melting glaciers and affecting the whole
Himalayan Mountain range and the water
supply for 2 billion or so people who
depend on it
it's thought that in the next 70 years
two-thirds of the glaciers there could
have disappeared well joining me now is
tensing choghiel Sherpa who's a grandson
of the last surviving member of that
1950s Expedition and also a glaciologist
in his own right thanks very much for
joining me tell me first a little bit
about your grandfather
my grandfather was a high altitude
Porter his main work was to take the
oxygen cylinders and then take it up to
Camp one chem2 and then the other part
of his job was also to go down to namche
and then cut down wooden logs and then
take them up carry them up and then use
it as uh like in nowadays you have
ladders but those days they used to use
those wooden logs as as a means to cross
the crevasses in the ice ball wow just
on wooden logs and those roles are
really important because the leader of
the Expedition and the both tenzie Norge
and Hillary made it very clear that they
were just the point of a pyramid and all
those people in the pyramid to get them
up there were crucial
yes exactly and that is I guess it's a
teamwork mountaineering is basically a
teamwork so you need everyone there and
it's it's a team effort yeah absolutely
he must be or should be very proud of
his role there but tell me I mean from
what he's seen and from what you study
how much has changed in that Himalayan
region in terms of the glaciology
uh the glitches here like to be from a
scientific perspective uh with the
changing climate they have had changed
quite a lot the landscape is getting
more and more dynamic as you speak
especially in these recent decades these
places that have been facing a rapid
recession and loss of its mass but going
back to my grandfather
um so my grandpa is the eldest person in
our village so he has had seen changes
within the environment that he lives in
and in the people as well so with the
environment one of the most prominent
changes that he feels is the intensity
of snowfall that he used to get like
during his childhood he used to see a
lot of snowfall and then these snowfall
are part of our culture and that he is
he sort of observes that it's not as it
used to be so the snowfall is is much
less than it used to be is that what he
observes yes uh that's exactly what he
observed and I can say that as well
because I live uh the initial years of
my life in namche Bazar that's the
village I come from and I used to love
playing in the snowfall quite a lot like
I used to play too much that my mom used
to come and beat me and so that's one of
the fond memories I have of my Village
playing in the snow and now when you see
in the village we don't get as much snow
as before and if you go take a look at
the signs it it also correlates with
that because the snowfall intensity and
the snowfall amount is also gradually
decreasing in the recent years I have
been to tanamji Bazaar where you were
brought up and indeed
um in the 50th anniversary of this
Ascent of Everest I went went up to to
base camp which was extraordinary
um do you think I would see changes even
now in the in the last 20 years that the
glaciers have shrunk
um I think you would like the fact that
why we study glaciers is because they
are the most visible indicators of
climate change so changes in these
glaciers and in the amount of snow cover
would be quite visible to you as well if
you remember correctly yeah well we got
a few pictures that that might help us
out but
um but what you're saying about snowfall
is is fascinating but also worrying
because with temperatures if you've got
temperatures Rising so more melt and
less snow falling I I'm guessing that's
going to accelerate the The
Disappearance of glasses exactly like
that's that's the worst case scenario
for a glacier because Glacier the the
key ingredient for a glacier is snow and
this is just a system that is balanced
within the amount of snowfall that is
received an amount of melt that it
experiences but now we have the worst
case scenario is less and less snowfall
and more and more temperature increase
so that is this worst case scenario and
just very briefly what should the world
be doing to preserve the glaciers of the
Himalayas
um
so climate change is uh the cause of
climate change is global but the effects
can be seen locally so in case of the
glaciers
um that the world now needs a wake-up
everybody needs to come together and
especially in case of our carbon
emissions we already need it's already
now now or never because uh had it been
like several years ago it would have
been better but now we are at this point
that we're in a Tipping Point of it
might be irreversible it
well that's it for this week a week when
I had a rare privilege of being able to
sleep on the job next week I'll be here
asking the question about how come a
coal mine that's been told to close is
still open in the meantime you can catch
up with all your environment news on the
Sky News website or app or by scanning
the QR code that has appeared on your
screen right now that's it see you back
here next week
foreign
[Music]